- Le pape Francoiscacacacacacac.
Après ses excuses pour
les gestes de nombreux
membres de l'Église dansueueueue
la fin de son voyage avec
un mot inattendu : génocide.
En 2015, le rapport
de la Commission vérité
et réconciliation qualifiait
déjà lesdededededededededededed.
Michèle Audette milite depuis
des années pour que le terme
soit reconnu plus largement.UDUt
membre de la communauté innue
- Maintenant, ça fait le tour
de la planète. C'est importantlr
le plan de la guérison,
mais sur le plan aussi...
juridique.
"Il a vu, il a compris
notre douleudididit
cette survivante d'un ancien
pensionnat au Manitoba.
a évoqué d'autres génocides,
notammcececelui de l'Arménie
en 2015, pour la première fois.
Mais ces reconnaissa
se font rares.
ALAIN CREVIER, spéisisiste
des nouvelles du Vatican
- C'est rare, c'
qu'un chef d'État débarque
dans un pays esesese : "Chez
vous, il y a eu un génocide."
C'est rare
Ça peut pas laisser indifférent.
Certaintntnt pas les premiers
peuples qui ont été l'objet
de
peut-être qu'ils pourraient
lplplper davantage l'Église,
mais n'empêche qu'il y a quelque
important, à mon avis.
- Cet ancienndndnd chef
de la Nation huronne-wendate
croit que la réconciliation
KONRAD SIOUI, ancien grand chef
Nationonononne-wendat de Wendake
- On vient de régler la vérité,
là, il reste la réconciliation.
qu'avec la venue du pape,
l l la semaine qu'on vient
de passer, avec la compréhension
que plusieurs ont faite, toutie,
même les gens à travers
le monde, la réconciliation
devient plus facile.
- Fatigué et avec
une santé fragile,
le pape Francois souhaite
maintenant ralentir le rythme. e
à se retirer, et son voya
au Canada pourrait
être son dernier. Ici Charlotte,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.